[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition locale nous
sommes le lundi 9 mai voici les titres
ce 9 mai marque la journée de l'europe
une date symbolique qui renvoie la
signature de la déclaration schuman du 9
mai 1950 pour nom de l'union européenne
le point dans ce journal plusieurs
événements seront organisés dans le
département à demain mardi 10 mai marque
une autre journée commémorative à celle
du souvenir de l'esclavagé et de son
abolition
pour l'occasion le collectif saint
quentinois pour la semaine de
l'esclavagé organisé à dimanche la 12e
édition de sa journée europe expositions
spectacles ou encore produits artisanaux
étaient au rendez vous et puis
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines proposer une découverte du vélo
ce week-end un événement qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre de l'opération nationale
mais à vélo aperçu des services en place
location atelier de réparation ou encore
associations
[Musique]
mais avant de débuter ce journal un
point sur les élections législatives
2022 on connaît désormais les candidats
à l'air m investis dans les yvelines
parmi eux on retrouve sept candidats
sortants quand jean noël barrot béatrice
piron marie lebey quoi encore ayez le
brunch iv et puis des nouvelles têtes
font leur apparition comme pour la
première circonscription où le parti a
investi charles rodwell à la place de
didier baichère et puis car les olives
aussi pour la 12ème circonscription et
avec le retour de nadia est actuellement
un ministre délégué a chargé de la ville
pour la 7e circonscription
et puis dans le reste de l'actualité je
vous le disais en titre aujourd'hui nous
célébrons elle la journée de l'europe
pourquoi et quelles sont les objectifs
les explications de philippe le guen
coordinateur de la maison jean monnet de
bazoches sur guyonne pour le parlement
européen
c'est une commémoration on commémore le
lancement de la première communauté
européenne le 9 mai 1950 à travers ce
qu'on a appelé le le discours du salon
de l'horloge du quai d'orsay
prononcé par robert schuman à l'époque
qui était ministre des affaires
étrangères est écrit par jean monnet et
ce texte a été écrit ici même à la
maison jean monnet quelle que ce
quelques jours avant d'être prononcé le
9 mai 1950 par ge robert schuman donc on
a pris cette date comme date symbolique
du lancement de finalement la
construction européenne c'est lundi 9
mai donc la journée de l'europe l'europe
célèbre la signature de la déclaration
schuman du 9 mai 1950 texte pionnier de
la construction européenne parmi les
pères fondateurs jean monnet il
ambitionnait même de bâtir une europe de
la défense et ça bien avant que le
projet ne sorte de nouveau et ne soit
évoquée aujourd'hui avec notamment
l'émergence eu de la guerre en ukraine à
le reportage de grégory canal et dans sa
demeure de bazoches sur guyonne où
l'homme à résider jusqu'à sa mort en
1979 tout ce que nous défendons
aujourd'hui
deviendrait lettre morte si une savions
dans les prochaines semaines et les
prochains mois crédibiliser notre
capacité en européen
avec nos coopérations nos alliés nos
alliances à nous défendre aussi et à
défendre en particulier
notre flanc oriental une vision qui
n'est pas nouvelle soixante dix ans
avant emmanuel macron jean-monnet
envisageait déjà d'organiser la défense
de l'europe l'inspirateur de la
déclaration schuman rédigé à bazoches
sur guyonne veut aller plus loin qu'une
communauté du charbon et de l'acier
le commissaire au plan français
imaginent l'idée d'une armée européenne
à l'été 1950 il présente son projet à
rené pleven président du conseil
français en plein contexte de guerre
froide et de guerre de corée les
américains un site beaucoup les
européens à
s'organiser pour
reconstituer une force militaire et donc
l'idée c'est ben de lancer cette
communauté européenne de défense c'est à
dire une armée européenne qui serait
placée sous commandement de l'otan mais
qui serait composé de deux forces
militaires qui proviendraient de tous
les pays qui sont membres de la première
communauté européenne donc les six pays
membres dont l'allemagne le 27 mai 1952
après des mois de négociations le traité
instituant la cod est signée à paris la
communauté européenne de défense
regroupe aux côtés de la france l'italie
la belgique les pays bas le luxembourg
et l'allemagne de l'ouest de table
interactive rappelle cet épisode à la
maison jean monnet à bazoches sur
guyonne les pays membres mettent en
commun
des soldats des forces militaires qui
sont placés sous le commandement d'une
haute autorité indépendante elle même
sous commandement de l'otan et donc on a
finalement une arme et un peu c'est un
mode fédéral si vous voulez 1,40
division de 13 mille soldats sous
uniforme commun sont évoqués mais le
projet soulève des débats houleux en
france voir l'allemagne réarmer quelques
années après la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale suscite de nombreuses craintes
une bo liste et communistes s'unissent
contre le traité qui a rejeté le 30 août
1954 par l'assemblée nationale la
communauté européenne de défense est
déjà mise en échec ça va même provoqué
la démission de jean monnet qui était le
président de la haute autorité du
charbon et de l'acier à luxembourg qui
décident de finalement jeter l'épongé
la construction européenne s'orientera
finalement sur les questions de commerce
et de nucléaire civil le thème de la
défense ne sera que très peu évoqué
jusqu'à la création en 2004 de l' agence
européenne de la défense l'idée d'une
défense européenne commune elle est
reçue rhji cette année avec le début de
la guerre en ukraine
et puis à l'occasion de la journée de
l'europe la maison jean monnet à a reçu
ce lundi une classe venus de mayotte
douze jeunes du département d'outre-mer
qui découvrent en ce moment les
institutions européennes après la visite
chez des parlement européen de bruxelles
et strasbourg ils se sont donc rendus à
dans la demeure de bazoches sur guyonne
considéré comme le berceau de l'europe
puisque c'est ici qu'a été rédigé la
déclaration schuman
et comme chaque année autour de cette
fameuse journée de l'europe la ville de
saint germain les organisent elles sont
à nu elles donc marché européen il aura
lieu ce samedi 14 mai marque milutinovic
vous êtes avec nous pour en parler
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ce soir
c'est avec un grand plaisir vous êtes
conseiller municipal chargé des
relations internationales donc à
saint-germain-en-laye déjà pour
commencer pourquoi c'est important de
célébrer l'europe chaque année écoutez
je pense que l'important c'est un petit
peu ce qu'il en est dit dans les
différents reportages c'est qu'en fait
l'europe et est au coeur de notre vie
est au coeur de
de l'avis de chacun de chaque citoyen
depuis plus de 70 ans et saint germain
en laye qui est une ville ouverte une
ville bienveillante une ville dont
l'international est vraiment dans l'adn
de la ville ne peut pas ne pas célébrer
l'europe à sa manière pour faire une
sorte de fête de l'europe et donc
pourquoi finalement ce marché vous venez
de dire ça parce qu'il ya un caractère
international concrètement comment ça va
se passer alors concrètement comment ça
va se passer c'est un c'est un marché
sur lequel qui est en fait plutôt une
fête de l'europe il va y avoir une plus
d'une trentaine d'exposants
des commerçants qui vont vendre des
produits spécifiques qui viendront chez
eux de leurs différents pays des
produits alimentaires mais pas
uniquement des produits typiques de
chacun des pays mais également et fait
important
notre jumelage nous avons cinq jumelages
à saint-germain-en-laye donc quatre
européens ils sont tous représentés
chacun fera représenter nous avons aussi
avoir la maison de l'europe des yvelines
qui fête également ses 20 ans cette
année qui aura un stand important sur
lequel il y aura d'ailleurs des membres
des jeunes du conseil municipal lycéens
qui expliqueront l'europe aux jeunes et
aux moins jeunes des vies d'amendé et
aussi nouveauté cette année un stand de
la maison des associations de saint
germain qui va pouvoir représenter les
associations qui oeuvre en europe d'une
manière ou d'une autre et qui peuvent
pas tous avoir un stand lors de ceux de
cette journée justement là vous parlez
de certaines thématiques comme le
jumelage ça ne se sera donc la 16e
édition elle sera dédiée donc plusieurs
thématiques vous en avez citer
quelques-unes est l'actuelle présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne les jumelages et les 20 ans
de la maison de l'europe des ebeam
comment vous avez fait ses choix
finalement j'ai envie dès que c'était un
petit peu naturelle d'abord les
jumelages vous savez notre plus ancien
jumelage à plus de 47 ans d'un jumelage
avec avec une ville allemande à
chêne-bourg d'ailleurs
il y aura sur le stand de ce jumelage
pendant ce samedi une délégation des
pompiers de notre ville jumelle
d'aschaffenburg qui seront présents il
ya aussi aussi quelque chose qui est
important c'est que nous avons aussi un
jumelage avec avec la pologne une ville
qui s'appelle constantinoise ournac et
du côté de varsovie et avec ce qui s'est
passé en ukraine avec cette guerre qui
est aux portes qui nous touche tous nous
avons une et non celle de solidarité
très important et les fins germanois les
saint germanoise et les gens de de
beaucoup de communes environnantes ont
fait des dons et grâce au jumelage que
nous avons avec eux qu'on sente signaux
en agrafes au rotary qui a financé grâce
à la communauté
des scouts ukrainien des des comités
religieuse chrétienne et de beaucoup
d'associations nous avons pu envoyer
trois camions
dans notre ville jumelle pour les
réfugiés une craignent un qui sont au
nombre de plus de 3000 dans notre ville
jumelle et plus de 3 millions et vais
également des camions directement
en ukraine donc je crois que le crâne
n'est pas dans l'europe telle que nous
pouvons définir aujourd'hui tels que ça
a été dit mais nous avons une pensée
très forte pour nos concitoyens pour eux
et pour toute la générosité que nous
avons essayé de donner spontanément à
travers ces jumelages finalement il y
aura un clin d'oeil donc au conflit
craignant absolument notamment sur le
jeu sur sol sur le stand de jumelage
avec la ville de constantine et oran et
bien vous avez fait le point un peu sur
les stands de tout à l'heure puisque
l'accent sera mis sur les états membres
de l'union européenne qui aura à peu
près 30 35 secondes l'objectif c'est
quoi c'est de faire voyager des données
un peu d information touristique
maintient tout ça c'est surtout de faire
la fête je vais et vous imaginez
qu'après ces deux ans de vaches maigres
si je peux me permettre de lire comme ça
ça fait donc c'est la seizième édition
mais en fait ça fait 18 ans que ça
existe sauf que les deux dernières
années pour les raisons que sanitaires
que nous connaissons tous nous n'avons
pas pu organiser 7,7
cette fête de l'europe ce marché
européen c'est également aussi le
lancement des activités de printemps
d'été de notre ville de saint germain
qui est une ville qui rayonne kiki et
qui est vraiment ouverte et qui est aime
beaucoup faire la fête et un beau coup
et ce marché européen rentre vraiment
dans le début de cette saison voilà
est-ce que donc à côté de ces stands là
vous avez parlé un petit peu il y aura
de la gastronomie un petit peu des
récents tout ça est ce que rossi des
animations par exemple à côté alors il y
aura beaucoup d'animations notamment
pour les jeunes il y aura mes mecs pour
les mois généralement il va y avoir un
quiz il va y avoir un jeu de piste il va
y avoir sur la place des victoires qui
est à côté de la place des marchés
grande roue en bois il va y avoir des
montages de cap là il va y avoir des du
maquillage pour les enfants donc
vraiment vraiment faire la fête de
l'europe à saint germain en laye et
petit clin d'oeil comme vous savez c'est
la présidence française de l'europe
actuellement et mémé la france et pas
uniquement les la métropole ce sont
aussi nos autres maires et le clin
d'oeil que nous avons c'est que nous en
avoir une fanfare créole qui va
déambuler dans la ville de saint germain
l'après midi qu'il sorte de clin d'oeil
festif au fait que la france préside
l'europe actuellement parfait est ce que
ce marché c'est aussi peut-être une
manière de sensibiliser le public qui
viendra sur place sensibiliser le public
peut-être à l'europe mais aussi aux
institutions européennes alors c'est
très important ce que vous dites parce
qu'effectivement il ya la partie
effectivement des expositions des stands
de la nourriture des différents pays etc
mais il ya aussi le fait que ce que nous
essayons de promouvoir ces deux fêtes de
faire comprendre à chacun d'entre nous
que nous sommes que l'europe est au
coeur de nos vies que l'europe n'est pas
uniquement des technostructures comme on
dit mais qu' on y lit à des concret dans
chacun de notre vie de tous les jours ce
qu'a fait l'europe depuis plus de 70 ans
c'est concret dans notre vie et c'est
pour ça que nous sommes entre autres
avec la maison de l'europe des yvelines
que ce seront des jeunes aussi d'une
certaine façon qu'ils feront
vraiment montrer que finalement ben
l'europe c'est pas c'est pas une théorie
c'est pas uniquement bruxelles ou
strasbourg mais c'est dans le quotidien
chacun de nous est donc tout ça c'est
accessible à tous on l'a dit ça se
passera samedi 14 août et ce sera de 10
heures à 18 heures 30 ce sera place du
marché neuf et place de la victoire
absolument et j'imagine qu'on peut
retrouver les informations sur le sujet
la ville il y avait des gros shows qui
vont être distribués ça a été dans le
journal olivier également parfait donc
n'hésitez pas à faire un tour sur le
site de saint germain en laye pour
connaître le programme
merci beaucoup marc milutinovic avoir
été avec nous elle je le rappelle vous
êtes conseiller municipal chargé aux
relations internationales pour la ville
de saint-germain-en-laye mur fiez-vous
[Musique]
et dans le cadre de sa présidence
française de l'union européenne
l'université paris saclay a été choisi
pour co organiser l'événement wire c'est
la douzième édition de la semaine à des
régions innovantes en europe et elle se
tient du 11 au 13 mai ce sera sur le
campus centrale supélec à gif-sur-yvette
les explications à 2 michel mariton
vice-président de l'université il était
interviewé par grégory canal et regarder
c'est un événement qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre de la présidence française de
l'union européenne c'est un événement
qu'il dédie à l'innovation avec un focus
particulier sur les régions où cette
année le focus particulier c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'innovation de rupture il
ya des innovations qui apporte une vraie
discontinuité un vrai et en large y
élargissement par exemple aller aux
applications d'une technologie
un premier objectif bien sûr qu'ils
aient de kate se rencontrer de
travailler discuter de l'échangé des
bonnes des bonnes pratiques de définir
d'analyser les manques de notre
dispositif d'une novation active en
europe et des signes définir des
améliorations par exemple ce qu'on
appelle le scale up c'est à dire la
capacité à faire accélérer des startups
en industrialisant les innovations pour
leur permettre des rita blement de créer
de la valeur économique à l'échelle du
continent européen
[Musique]
la première journée sera à dominante
institutionnels donc il s'agira de faire
un petit peu le bilan des dispositifs
existants d'analyser les menaces les les
opportunités nous aurons des
intervenants donc des grandes
institutions européennes également du
ministère la deuxième journée on ira
plutôt une musique de zoom avec des
ateliers de travail en parallèle donc
ils se pencheront sur des sujets des
points d'amélioration bien d'identifier
du dispositif européen les participants
de huawei dans la troisième et dernière
partie troisième et dernière journée de
l'événement iront visiter des
laboratoires et des centres de recherche
pour voir sur le terrain la traduction
de ses efforts en faveur de l'innovation
et puis le 10 mai autres journées
commémoratives c'est la date de la
journée nationale des mémoires de la
traite de l'esclavagé et de leurs
abolitions
et à cette occasion l'association il est
monté un collectif pour la semaine de la
mémoire de l'esclavagé organisé le
samedi 8 mai la 12e édition de la
journée europe elle a proposé notamment
une exposition appelée afro note tour le
reportage de selliers agathe son goût et
céline charles
favoriser la compréhension et la
transmission de l'histoire par une
plongée au coeur des cultures c'est ce
que fait chaque année le collectif pour
la semaine de la mémoire de l'esclavagé
de saint quentin en yvelines organisée
depuis 2009 la journée au port en
hommage à tous ceux qui ont combattu
contre l'esclavagé et ses séquelles
quand les jambes sont connaissent bien
l'histoire quand les gens comprennent un
peu c'est que les gens ressentent à
travers ce qui n'est moi là on espère
que c'est jacky comportement pourquoi
cette attitude raciste du racisme ou
puis se disant allez en aluminium notre
but c'est d'apprendre et de partager
avec nous tout le monde pour mieux vivre
ensemble au programme un marché
tropicale avec une vente de produits
artisanaux un stand de maquillage une
tombola et surtout une exposition phare
la fraude autour on se tendre
représentant 11 pays étaient présents on
va visiter l'afrique les caraïbes
l'amérique est vraiment l'objectif c'est
de faire découvrir aux enfants et aux
plus grands aussi les différents pays où
il qu'on a envie de mettre en avant et
tout leur patrimoine justement culturels
ou historiques
donc on a un peu revisiter des
classiques comme le twister par exemple
qu'on adapte et on a aussi revisité par
exemple des pièces pour justement faire
découvrir des personnages d'haïti tous
les stands dans le marché
on l artiste c'est à dire voilà un
panneau fille présente à un artiste en
fait c'est une forme de dommages à ces
artistes là là il s'agit déjà et jacob
desvarieux qui est le créateur du zouk
une journée d'échangé de partage qui
célèbre la loi taubira le 10 mai 2001 la
france est devenue le premier pays au
monde à reconnaître la traite négrière
et l'esclavagé comme crime contre
l'humanité
dans le cadre de l'opération nationale
mais à vélo l'agglomération à de saint
quentin en yvelines a voulu faire
découvrir ce sport à ses habitants elle
c'était le samedi 7 mai au programme
location-achat formation et réparation
de la vélostation de sky à plusieurs
partenaires étaient sur place le
reportage de céline charles mathilde de
franck où cet enfant le retour des beaux
jours et avec eux l'opération mais à
vélo une initiative nationale qui vise à
promouvoir le vélo sous toutes ses
formes pour l'occasion saint quentin en
yvelines a proposé une matinée de
découverte à la vélostation plusieurs
associations locales étaient présentes
objectif présenter les services en place
on aide les personnes réparer leur que
même leurs vélos donc on leur apprend
les petites réparations tout ce qui est
crevaison changement de patins de frein
réglages de dérailleur on fait aussi de
la vente de vélos d'occasion la vie nos
stations service qui est proposée par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui propose trois services
différents donc il ya de la location de
vélos la location de places de
conseillers et un atelier de réparation
aujourd'hui dont nous sommes 50 m pour
nous représenter une information
mécanicien vélo est aussi technique vélo
c'est surtout la rapaces la maintenance
la réparation de vélos parmi les
associations le groupe vélo sky antenne
de l'association mieux se déplacer à
bicyclette qui réunit une centaine
d'adhérents plusieurs actions et
activités sont proposées dont une pour
apprendre à faire du vélo c'est
l'opportunité pour des personnes qui
n'ont jamais appris à faire du vélo
devenir en confiance dans un tout petit
groupe généralement on a trois quatre
élèves maximum en même temps ils m'ont
rassuré m'ont appris la bea bail à
chaque fois beaucoup d'encouragements et
puis aujourd'hui c'est pas parfait mais
deux mois après j'essaie en faire je
peux faire un pack ou une journée qui
vise aussi à démontrer que le vélo est
un sport qui se démocratise de plus en
plus je suis de l'eau quotidiennement
pour aller faire des courses au centre
commercial pour venir la médiathèque
avec vous pour aller ailleurs c'est le
moyen le plus rapide le plus économe
c'est le moyen le plus écologique on a
quand même beaucoup de pistes cyclables
bien entretenir font croire aux
associations locales faux
se dire qu'avec la présence des
vélodromes justement on va pousser dans
le sens là et que ça deviendra vraiment
une ville amie des vélos et si vous avez
vous aussi l' envie de vous mettre au
vélo le groupe vélo sky vous donne
rendez vous le dimanche 5 juin pour
relier saint quentin en yvelines à paris
avec des milliers d'autres cyclistes
maire de trappes rentes entre 1966 et
1996 conseiller général et puis sénateur
des yvelines dans les années 70 et 80
elles ce sont les mandats du communiste
bernard hugo une figure emblématique
deux trappes honorer ce dimanche 8 mai
elle suite à sa disparition à l'âge de
90 ans le vendredi 19 mars 2021 la ville
a organisé une cérémonie d'hommage à la
merise au tour aux deux discours de
témoignages de lecture mais aussi de
chants l'occasion aussi de rendre un
hommage à sa femme monique décédé en
novembre 2020 une exposition photos
retraçant la vie de bernard et monique
hugo est visible donc à la merise jusqu
au vendredi à 13 mai avant une tournée
dans les bâtiments de la ville et c'est
la fin de ce journal merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis dans un instant
retrouver michael mais d'euros à la
présentation de votre magazine sportif
très bonne soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]